I don't like fat women I just think it's
a lack of discipline that when you see
somebody's overweight you gotta think to
yourself whenever you mention the word
fat and there's somebody's fat around
sometimes the time they always get a
French to it but you can only say that
you see if you're fat you're fat lack of
discipline that's what the men are
saying they're not saying oh yeah you
got a bit of what they're thinking well
anyway you can't control it eating
because you control money because you
control yourself and that's what they're
thinking about Bill got fat I see Pearl
going out there and doing the gym and
having a talk today about more protein
less carbs and all that